hallo mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren das hier ist jule immer mit der
ruhe
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einem
neuen video der gugl play game on
kampagne meine damen und herren julia
und ich haben uns heute mal wieder ein
spiel ausgesuchte nehmen wir uns betteln
wollen und zwar im wort und spiel
er geht es darum dass uns buchstaben
gegeben werden und mit diesen buchstaben
müssen wir wörter formen
wir haben uns hier ganz oldschool
sondern zettel vorbereitet mit einer
julis sparte und einer luca sparte und
wir werden nun abwechselnd jeder
insgesamt fünf level spielen und aus
jedem level werden wir uns das
schwierigste wort rausnehmen auf unsere
seite schreiben und dann werden wir nach
dem quasi jeder fünf wörter auf seiner
seite hat werden wir jeweils eine person
anrufen
und diese fünf wörtern das telefonat
unterbringen und wer mehr wörter schafft
der diese challenge gewonnen
juli fängt jetzt an mit dem ersten wort
das ist grau tatsächlich rau hat sie
auch schon hingekriegt also ich würde
sagen eines grau einfach oder ok judas
erstes wortes grau also juli addiert sie
das level 12 abgeschlossen
der krasseste begriff sage ich mal da
bzw dohmen war grau mit vier buchstaben
das heißt ich mache jetzt level 13
sieht ganz klar bei sie aber ich bin
recht gut da drin oder ich würde sagen
sie nehme ich also das ist das längste
wort her sonst noch nehmen dass ich
würde er mit ihr das spielen als mit
irgendwann anderen weil wir dir macht so
viel spaß jule also das bisher eher und
ehre ich würde sagen kann schon mal ihre
nehmen oder weil wenn also ein sternchen
dann ist das das wort auch relativ
schwer das letzte wort bei jule war das
her
also ich mach jetzt weiter mit level 15
da
[Musik]
gut gut und teuer also das letzte
dreistellige wort ist hier hat
wahrscheinlich ja genau ich würde aber
trotzdem haut nehmen weil wir haben ja
gesagt ich nehme immer das unternehmen
immer das schwierigste beziehungsweise
längste wort jude bei level 16 gramm ist
drin aber du nimmst auf jeden fall
gerade mein nächstes level ihm auf jeden
fall wer dann noch für ne sch
geschrieben ich vollidiot rübe das
nimmst du das ist das ok ich muss
übernehmen alter kommt nicht mal
kommentieren und du bist schon fertig
jeder nimmt so bleibt nun hier der
vorletzte begriffe mich freunde
[Musik]
ok ich im kies julis letztes wort kommt
jetzt hier freunde find ja feind musste
schon neben auf jeden fall also julis
fünf wörter stehen schon mein fünftes
wort kommt jetzt zu kommt er auf jeden
fall erstmal rein
drei wochen später ab erst noch
beschließen was ich hier für wörter
haben das letzte wort ist dann natürlich
zug wenn man es ja ein gibt ja okay wir
haben jetzt jeder fünf level geschafft
die wörter seht ihr hier mal
eingeblendet jula hatte graue ehre gramm
leib und feind und ich habe sie pries
und abzug dann heißt leute wir müssen
jetzt telefonieren so leute wenn jetzt
die cam bisschen gezwickt
das ist einfach besser vor dem ton wenn
ich dieses krasse micro hier vor uns
haben sondern dass kamera micro das
macht mir sind wenn wir jetzt auf
lautsprecher telefonieren einem das hier
sind die begriffe die wir jeweils sagen
müssen dass man schlucken wir anfangen
muss juli muss als erstes jemand anrufen
und zwar carola also falls ihr carola
nicht kennt
was machst du radio hause lampen ich
habe mir heute so ein pullover gekauft
der ist echt schön der brite keine
ahnung ich war in der ehrenstraße
irgendwie sind da queen aber ich weiß
noch nicht ob ich die soko zum anrufen
habe ich mir finden überlegt das ist ein
freund von lukas klappt ihr merkt sofort
dass luca den verarschen will
[Musik]
hey was geht
es könne ja nie alles gute hat sich
unter den ich war ich noch von youtube
video anrufe schon anders an als ich sie
verfolgen den anrufen endlich angegangen
und jan hat den drei minuten irgendein
release und florian die auch nicht
rangehen also ich hoffe dass meine
schwester an
hallo das geht weil wo bist du
ach so ja ich wollte eigentlich nur kurz
was fragen du bist ja auch morgen bei
carola ja schenkst du der irgendwas für
die haut oder so nichts mehr zusammen
also juni und ich habe etwas gekauft
also wir waren mal zum laden der
hiesigen wir üben ist total bescheuert
das war neuer daten in köln hier und die
haben irgendwie so ein paar geschenke
sachen daten wer etwas gekauft für die
haut für sie ich weiß nicht letztes mal
hat mir ein geschenk aber das hatte die
unter ihrem abzug stehen in der küche
und dann ist das irgendwie ein bisschen
schlecht geworden
deswegen sieht war das und ja das dann
halt in die küche gestellt und keine
ahnung
okay okay bis morgen
juli habe ich wohl den channels geworden
an der stelle würden wir das heutige
video ist allerdings auch beenden
freundin findet und in der beschreibung
einen link zu dem spiel wort guru also
wenn es euch gefallen hatte ich also ich
feiere die apple mega dann könnt ihr
euch das dort gern runterladen kostenlos
und findet in der beschreibung auch
einen link eingeblendet zu den besten
spielen 2018 in google places wir
befinden uns jetzt hier allerdings auch
in der hand card freunde hier findet ihr
ein logo doch mal eingeblendet zum spiel
wort dort könnt ihr euch das spiel wie
auch über den link in der infobox
downloaden und hier findet ihr auch das
andere video verlinkt was wir bisher zu
dieser google play game kampagne gemacht
haben nämlich asphalt 9
da sind ja nicht ein rennen
gegeneinander gefahren könnt ihr auch
gerne abdecken und sonst